[Applause]
if there is a grassroots body called the
white helmets of volunteers separate for
the people who actually started in
Istanbul it wasn't it didn't start Syria
was started by an English soldier in
Istanbul but if that body exists and
they and they go and help people after
you know either as sad or the Russians
or somebody else's drop bombs on them
then I I support them wholeheartedly
with every fiber of my being but all the
evidence points to the fact that that is
not the reality I don't know if you did
you did you see the the documentary that
won the Oscar I mean have you ever seen
anything so obviously scripted and
carefully shot
now Facebook and Google and YouTube and
whatever the way that most people get
their news and they use those the social
media you know in order to educate
themselves or find out what's going on I
see but it's being it is being the
content is being censored by the
corporation's that earn it so it so that
so it it won't be free I mean it's not
free now but it's and there they are
targeting I wouldn't be surprised if I
disappear because I'm anti-war
when I was making this this record I
just made this is the life we really
want the guy was producing the wreck of
producing this record with me started
telling me about a party
how arty was just pure propaganda
nothing but a pack of lies all that well
I want charity so I've said that you
can't see a documentary about fracking
on American television because they
weren't they're not interested in in in
tech and telling you anything about
anything
you